the jogan experience I just read a thing
about how Corporate trolling is a big
thing like buying these corporations are
buying in the ability to inform
misinformation there's a crazy Artic I
can't remember the statistic but of
posts on Reddit were from corporate
trolls or something like that what per
15% I think that thing I read was higher
I don't think but it's like holy [__]
it's a thing and which means it could
have been a thing then right so which is
why yeah go ahead even the people that
like we were talking about the Baby
Boomers not just being spoonfed the news
even the people that think they're one
level smarter are reading things that
are easily bought by a multi-billion
dollar Corporation something we you know
we wouldn't spend money on information
but why wouldn't they what a wild thing
to do to hire someone to get a narrative
out and to pretend you're a regular
person arguing online and it's totally
legal it's really exception new study at
least 15% of all Reddit content is
Corporate trolls trying to manipulate
public opinion now is that fraud what is
that it's not technically fraud what is
it though if you're pretending to be a
person should you have to sign a
contract when you use a social media
account like you know this Nikki Haley
lady I think she wants everybody to to
have to like expose their name and their
ID whenever they post but the problem
with that is then that discourages like
government whistleblowers things along
those lines like if someone has like
some important information that they
have to get out you know and also
foreign countries that'll kill people
you can't if you if you have the rules
apply to America you're going to have to
have those rules apply to other
countries how how many what percentage
of people that are on Twitter are from
the rest of the world outside of America
it's got to be pretty high so how are
you going to enforce that you're not
going to be able to but even if you did
like this idea that that's a good thing
like I see why they would say that but
you should at least have to somehow or
another prove that you're an individual
I don't know how you would do that
without giving up your information but
maybe you don't have to do it publicly
but there should be a way where we know
you're not a troll like [__] man the
only problem with that is like it's a
trap because the way is like a digital
ID and you don't want to give up a
digital ID right you don't want to have
like a thing that shows you everywhere
you go online because someone would be
able to just do things with that they'll
be able to manipulate you from that into
having something that's attached to
something else like whether it's a
vaccine passport or a social credit
score or you know centralized digital
currency that's on that phone with that
app with your unique ID this is how
we're going to stop bank fraud you're G
to have a unique ID nobody's going to be
able to steal your money your money's
All Digital now yeah technically they
could track everything about your life
so when you see look at somebody your
glasses can say how often they eat at
this restaurant and everything like so
the is the solution to just allow the
trolls allow corporate trolls and hope
that people are smart enough to realize
they're being [__] with but like what
if those corporate trolls are shifting
public opinion and it actually costs
lives that's where it gets weird like
what if they lie about something because
they don't want to have responsibility
for something that they did so they
obscure the truth with these corporate
trolls and it gets messy enough where
people just argue it out and they slide
through and you know when you think
about the intentions behind who would
they attack what types of things would
they try to manipulate it's the things
that would threaten them yeah need a
little clarification on this as I tried
to dig through the article the article
is paid paid for behind a medium so I
can't get there but paid for by trolls
right exactly have to pay to get in
there I said that wrong but uh right
what it actually says behind it is uh
15% of the top 100 subreddits found to
have content that was likely posted by
Bots or corporate trolls specifically
aimed at promoting certain companies or
organizations I don't know why if that's
why that's so hard to believe when we
know how many uh trolls are on Facebook
and Instagram and there's constant trols
I was looking at uh someone was someone
was getting attacked for something like
pretty minor but I was just like reading
the comments of this page and I do this
thing now where I'll go and I'll read
something that seems like a little weird
or off or something like and then I go
to their page oh you're a fake account
like this is a fake account you have no
posts you're you're restricted no one
can see it you have no um you know no
followers you have like 15 followers
like oh okay this is fake you got a fake
account yeah how many of these are there
how many of these are there that are
just constantly commenting on things and
trying to stir up [__] it's weird
it's but and it's legal so if right now
there's no law that prevents
corporations from hiring people to
pretend that they're a person or using
AI to pretend they're a person to put a
narrative out if that's not illegal like
what is that like what kind of deception
is that like you're not allowed to lie
right like if a corporation is found
that they're they're lying about data
they get fined if they if they're if
it's found out that they're lying about
environmental problems they've created
or whatever they get fined right they
get in trouble people could go to jail
but if you could just have like a bunch
of people constantly lying for you or if
it's AI have ai constantly lying for you
yeah obscuring the
truth publishing misleading papers right
AI could just start publishing
papers